he youtubers is Charlie everybody was
freaking out after the flash episode one
started dropping yesterday about the new
flash costume as well as Barry's
costumes so I'll explain what's going on
it's not quite what everyone thinks
I wasn't expecting on doing a new flash
video this soon but because people went
so crazy after iris and Wally started
posting from this set I figured it'd be
good just to get it out of the way so
I'll do a new round of the flash ring
giveaway - in what I'm going to do is
change the giveaway just a little bit
just because it seems like there's a
little confusion so I'll explain that at
the end of the video Rebeck but the
important thing kid Flash's costume and
I'll talk about Barry's costume in this
tube but the big thing is the qingyan
lines Dale the actor that plays Wally
West was posting on Instagram
along with Candice Patton because
apparently they were the first people
shooting on the first day now we know
danielle panabaker was there too so she
might have been filming separately in
her killer frost makeup and they didn't
want her to appear on camera just
because it might have been spoilery more
on that - because the flash production
office the tweeted that picture of the
title also just deleted their twitter
account so they got a big freakin
trouble for posting that but in a bunch
of separate posts Qingyun Lyons Vale was
posting pictures of his costume and
people took this to mean that he was
wearing the red flash costume so if you
don't read the comics there have been
two different times that Wally West has
worn a red flash costume it was back
during the modern age when Barry Allen
died he started wearing the Barry Allen
version of the costume then during Jeff
Jones run when he brought Barry Allen
back they changed his costume a little
bit but it was still red so it was a red
costume Wally West then again they just
brought back ginger Wally West during DC
rebirth and he was wearing his yellow
costume he went off to the Titans comic
book and started wearing a red version
of the yellow costume with his hair
sticking out the top so because we're
doing flash rebirth a lot of people were
like wait a minute now that Wally's kind
of the main version of the flash wall
Barry's away does that mean they're
doing the comic book thing where he
takes up the mantle and the red costume
at the same time because technically he
is the main version of the flash the
problem with this though is that kid
Flash's costume legs have always been
red it's always been solid yellow
on red so when you're looking at the
costume below the waist there's nothing
that's different they have changed his
costume but all they've done is made it
more form-fitting like the way they
change Barry's costume during the course
of season one he had sort of a Batman
problem so during the Batman Christopher
Nolan movies Batman wanted to be able to
turn his head so they had to make a more
modular version of the costume so
depending on what kind of scene they're
filming crank us that has three
different versions of the flash costume
so it's the same thing with Wally's
costume so even beyond the cosmetic
changes which is what most people talk
about when they talk about new costumes
like what is it going to look like they
also make functional updates and I don't
think that it was necessary but Candice
Patton came back and replied to this
post when people were freaking out
saying that
Wally's costume has always been read
like this there was an interview the kid
flash did earlier this year that I think
a lot of people missed where he talks
about potentially wearing a Barry
version of the costume where he says
it's not something that's on my radar I
feel as though there's so much story to
tell and Wally has so much growing to do
I'd like to see that journey continue
that's what I think is important we need
to see how these characters
realistically get to where they're
headed for he's basically saying that
he's not going to be wearing the red
costume he's still got a long way to go
there's a lot of character development
it also makes it sound like he's not
going anywhere anytime soon for a little
while I thought that it might be
possible that he would go on Titans
eventually but it sounds like if that's
going to happen it's not going to happen
till season five of the flash or much
later down the road but the Barry Allen
costume people are like is he going to
come back from the Speed Force with the
new version of the costume so in the
grand tradition of the flash yes the
costume changes a little bit every year
but I feel like people are thinking a
little further ahead than the show is
like they want him to be wearing the
2024 version of his costume that was the
one with the extra gold belt with all
the highlights it did look brighter
there was some more Flair on it but I
wasn't the hugest fan of it I feel like
there are better improvements they can
make with the color tone and the
highlights that aren't quite as gaudy is
like all that extra gold on him I felt
like they could have done a much better
job with that future flash costume they
always take inspiration from things they
see in the future like
saw a vision of the white emblem so he's
like you know what we should do that
that's really cool and it became the
self-fulfilling prophecy our city's very
own Scarlet speedster disappeared in an
explosion of life I have to say I'm
really digging the brighter red suit and
the white on the symbol let's go wait a
second
suppose we now change the color on your
suit will it be because we got the idea
from this picture that would mean we're
living in a causal Nexus wow this is so
trippy
so with these wearing the costume when
he does come back from the Speed Force
it's mostly going to look like the old
version of the costume until Cisco
literally builds a new one the biggest
change to his costume I think will be
the flash ring so a lot of people have
asked why haven't they done the flash
ring yet well one it's because the rings
are mostly associated with marriage
they've been building towards the Barry
iris marriage so I think you can chart
the timeline of Barry using the flash
ring with whatever wedding they end up
happening on the show whenever they
decide to do that that could be at the
end of this season that could be at the
beginning of next season but it just
makes sense that if they're going to get
married there's going to be a wedding
ring that ring would be the flash ring
and that's when he would start using it
more
nobody's been talking about it but I
think the other big reason why they
haven't used the flash ring yet is
because it requires liberal special
effects and that would cost them a lot
more money this is gonna be fun
it's a lot cheaper for them to just turn
the camera around and have Barry be in
the costume like it's really cool
watching savitur climb out of that
costume but it's really expensive and it
blows a lot of time so they do it a
couple times and then they find really
quick ways to just jump over that in the
future so they have the technology they
can totally do the flash ring now I
think they're just holding back because
of the wedding and because it's kind of
expensive to do it in every single
episode and in the comics Barry doesn't
even use the flash ring that much
anymore the ginger Wally West makes fun
of him because he can actually use the
Speed Force to manifest his costume he
doesn't even need a ring to do it
anymore he literally just wills it into
existence so I think the show at some
point will learn to do that too
but it's one of those advanced abilities
that they tend to hold off till later
seasons so when you're thinking about
new flash costume just think just extra
bright highlights like color change but
other than that I don't think it's going
to change that much and just to clarify
the flash ring giveaway I probably don't
do this enough what I do is I pick the
winner randomly from the comments when I
say leave a comment it's not a comment
about winning the flash ring it's just
meant to be a comment about the flash TV
show in general I'll just remind
everyone about that before the season 4
episode video start but what's going to
happen is there'll be some new
spider-man coming up new Game of Thrones
new Rick and Morty leave all your
requests in the comments below you can
click here to learn more about episode 1
and you can click here for brand new
Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight